so last week we talked about this
suggestion from Donald Trump that he
wants to end birthright citizenship via
executive order and we talked about a
few different layers of it one of the
discussions was is it a distraction from
the fact that people can actually vote
and affect change in terms of who
represents them and I said well it might
end up being one but I don't think it's
like a deliberately planted distraction
and then we got into the legal
conversation which is would it be legal
to end birthright citizenship via
executive order and of course most legal
experts said that no that that's not
something that would be legal and then
we talked kind of about the moral
element of it is birthright citizenship
a good thing or a bad thing but there's
a really important discussion to be had
that's not really being had which is
let's imagine that you got rid of
birthright citizenship however you do it
right executive order constitutional
amendment doesn't even matter let's
assume we get rid of birthright
citizenship how do you then determine
citizenship and it's a really important
question that might not seem like an
important one because there are people
who because they imagine for them the
problem with birthright citizenship is
what they believe to be brown people
coming in birthing kids and using those
kids as so-called anchor babies to then
stay in the United States but that's not
the only way in which people become
citizens of the United States in ways
that you might agree or disagree with
and if you eliminate birthright
citizenship it's not actually that
obvious how you put in place an outline
the mess method or methods through which
individuals can become citizens of the
United States because there are a whole
bunch of new issues and the main one is
how do you determine who is a citizen
the obvious one would be okay listen you
must be born to two people who are in
the United States legally doesn't mean
citizens but they've got to be here
legally well hold on a second you can be
here legally on a tourist visa for a
one-week visit have a baby the parents
were here legally at the time
the baby was born but they're not
citizens and they're not allowed to stay
indefinitely is is that what you're
looking to do when you might say David
no no you can't just be here legally you
must be born to two citizens of the
United States well hold on a second if
you have two legal permanent residents
here and they have a kid here they're
not citizens can the kid still be a
citizen mmm well that that's the sort of
another layer of questioning well so
what about at least one parent must be a
US citizen so are you saying you don't
care about one parent being undocumented
unless one parent is legally here
because this is kind of a big argument
to then say well I'm actually fine as
long as at least what as long as one of
the parents is a legal citizen but two
undocumented parents wouldn't be okay
that now seems like we're just arguing
in shades of grey so then you get to
what about a citizenship test what about
some kind of test to become a citizen a
citizen and you might say David no just
getting rid of birthright citizenship
doesn't mean that you now need to take a
test well hold on a second if birthright
is no longer a factor in citizenship
there are tens of millions of Americans
born in the United States to to legal
American citizens who would fail a basic
citizenship or civics test are you
suggesting we strip them of citizenship
and if so what country do they have to
go to and more importantly do you end up
in some kind of state of limbo until
you're old enough to even take the test
if you're born if where you're born no
longer is what determines citizenship
even people born in the United States to
to legal American citizens might be in
this limbo until they pass the test so
just because you might see this idea of
birthright citizenship as related to the
immigrants coming here to in this
crafty way birth the child to then get
all of these benefits this is just as
much about who should get citizenship as
it is about who shouldn't and just
because you've identified as some people
who watch the show primarily on the
right have
just because you've identified this
scenario where immigrants come here to
have a kid as some kind of strategy as
an example of someone who should not get
citizenship if you get rid of birthright
citizenship you have to then establish a
new set of rules as to who does get
citizenship and it's not as easy as some
people believe that it is
and then lastly but by the way let's
step back from citizenship altogether
from the really big hypocrisy with the
idea of using an executive order to
change how the Constitution is
interpreted do the Second Amendment
people that Trump mentioned during the
campaign about maybe they would do
something about Hillary Clinton do the
Second Amendment people really want to
open the door to the reinterpretation of
the Constitution by presidential
executive order because you can't
justify reinterpreting the 14th
amendment by executive order without
allowing for the possibility of
reinterpreting the second amendment by
executive order and I know that they'll
come up with some reason why it's
different but reinterpreting amendments
by executive order can't only be limited
to the amendments that the right wants
to reinterpret and for their sake not
that I'm their strategist in any way it
seems like that's opening up a Pandora's
box that I don't think that they really
would want to open send me your thoughts
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me
you have a very long list of books that
you've been meaning to read you only
have so many hours in the day and that's
why blink astiz so amazing they take the
most important information the themes
the insights from each book and they
distill it into a 15-minute audio book
that you can listen to in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on blink
Asst our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is comm slash Pakman that's B
Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n